(woman vocalizing)
- [Chani] My planet
Arrakis is so beautiful
when the sun is low.
Rolling over the sands, you
can see spice in the air.
(dramatic music)
The outsiders ravaged our
lands in front of our eyes.
(explosions blasting)
(men screaming)
Their cruelty to my
people is all I've known.
(woman vocalizing)
What's to become of our world?
Paul.
(Paul gasps)
- [Duncan] My boy.
- [Paul] Duncan, can I
trust you with something?
- Yes, always.
You know that.
- I've been having dreams
about a girl on Arrakis.
I don't know what it means.
- Dreams make good stories,
but everything important
happens when we're awake.
Hey, you put on some muscle?
- I did?
- No.
- We are House Atreides.
There is no call we do not answer.
There is no faith that we betray.
Smile, Gurney.
- I am smiling.
- [Leto] The emperor asks us
to bring peace to Arrakis.
House Atreides accepts!
- I know you.
There's something awakening in my mind.
- [Chani] You need to face your fears.
- Come with me.
- You need to be ready.
You've never met the Harkonnens before.
They're not human.
They're brutal!
- [Wellington] The
duke's son sees too much.
- [Vladimir] This is my dune.
Kill them all.
- God in heaven.
(explosion blasting)
Get everything with guns off the ground!
Go!
- This is an extermination.
They're picking my family off one by one.
- Let's fight like demons.
- Dad, what if I'm not the
future of House Atreides?
- A great man doesn't seek to lead.
He's called to it.
But if your answer is no,
you'll still be the only
thing I ever needed you to be.
My son.
(woman vocalizing)
If anything happens,
will you protect Paul?
- With my life.
- No!
Only together can we stand a chance.
- It's time.
(woman vocalizing)
- Hello, everyone, and
welcome to the Academy's
Visiting Artists Film Series
FilmAid edition for writing.
I'm Vanessa Taylor,
and today I will be speaking
with the screenwriters of Dune,
Eric Roth, Jon Spaihts,
and Denis Villeneuve,
who also directed and produced the film.
I am thrilled to be here today
to have the opportunity
to talk with you all
about this beautiful film,
and I will just dive in because
I have so many questions.
I would like to start with you, Eric,
and I would love to know
what kind of dialogue
you and Denis had sort of going into this
as you approached your draft.
- Well, we started kind of blind in a way,
I mean, except for, obviously, Denis.
We both knew the book very well.
- And you had also, had you
also read it a long time ago?
I know, Denis, you had read it
when you were in your early teens.
Eric, at what point had you--
- I had read it when I
was in my early teens.
But then when Denis talked
to me about doing it,
I obviously reread it
thoroughly, more than once
and wanted to see what were the pitfalls.
And I also was asked to
write a long treatment
for the estate 'cause
I wanted to make sure
we weren't going to besmirch the piece
and take off on some kind of flyer.
But Denis is a wonderful partner
and said, he gave me the right to dream.
And I take dreams
and I go a little bit
far afield sometimes.
And he also, which we've
talked about a number of times,
I said, "What would be
most important to you?"
And he felt to somehow
show the women, the
importance of the women in it
and make the piece have a
female quality, feminine quality
that would be in keeping with Sand Dune,
those kind of things, and
so that the Bene Gesserit
became as important in the
book and maybe more important
to what the whole sort
of theme of the movie is.
So, yeah, and I think we
tried to figure out a way
to tell a really, a resounding story,
which was given to us by Frank Herbert,
and not to go too far afield,
but yet try in the most concise way.
And I'm not the most concise writer,
so this was a challenge,
and he always had to have me
keep my feet on the ground.
And I will say, just to go
a slightly step further,
and maybe this would be
something you talk about
down the line, this is, to
me, such a unique experience
because I've been involved with
other sort of writing teams
and sort of rewrote each
other and worked together.
But this is the most
seamless that I can think of
where people worked to the
best of their abilities
on the things that they
knew how to do very well,
where I don't think you can
tell one from the other.
And so it's, I think, a
really unique thing to see.
And so I'm very proud of
that for everybody involved.
- I'll go to you next, Denis.
I'm wondering what you were
looking for at this stage
in a collaborator.
- Oh, it's,
I asked Eric at the
beginning because I was,
I had read several of his previous work,
and I was always impressed
by the depth of his culture,
his reference, his link, his
relationship with spirituality.
And also, it's true that
one thing that I love
in Eric's writing is how
we approached femininity.
I liked the idea that someone
who had the more of an
approach of an historian,
someone that will approach
this book with that view.
So that's why Eric was
the name I had in mind
to approach the beast, because frankly,
I don't know about Jon, on Jon's side,
but me, I was as excited
as terrorized, (laughing)
and I needed someone with
wisdom and the experience
to crack it at the beginning.
- Right.
I would love, in a
moment, to go back, Eric,
to what you said about pitfalls
and ask you all about what
those pitfalls might have been
that you were trying to avoid.
But first, I would love to know, Denis,
so you came in, I believe, after Eric
and were writing on this,
which you don't always do
on your directing projects.
And I just wondered
what you hoped to bring
as you began writing on this work.
- I started making movies by
writing my own feature films.
My first four feature films,
I was the unique screenwriter
on the four of them.
The more I learned about writing,
the more I realized how little I know
and how much I needed to share
writing with other people.
And my dream was to,
after having directed a few
movies written by other writers,
my dream for Dune was to share the writing
with other writers with more experience,
that have tremendously
more talent than me.
But I wanted to stay close to
the object of the adaptation.
I wanted to feel the
intimate, the intimacy,
to try to infuse
in Eric and in Jon visual
ideas that were haunting me.
My dream was to try to
bring back to the surface
images that I had dreamed
of when I read the book
when I was 13 years old.
And I wanted those images to,
to stay in relationship with
those images and try to,
I don't know, to suggest
them to Eric and Jon
as we were, as the writing
was moving forward.
And Eric was very generous.
The idea was, and I loved it,
it was like a paradise for me,
to take Eric's work, and
I had this benediction
just to shape it to,
not shaping, I apologize,
not the right word.
It's just that Eric will
agree that what he brought
was a very impressive screenplay
but that was a bit too
ambitious for our resources.
- Agreed, agreed.
- And I had to add, with his benediction,
I took the elements, not
reshape, but play with it.
- No, you did.
No, you did, and you did a,
I must say, I mean, I've worked
with probably 20 directors
and I was always, I'm always
sensitive when the directors
do what they, they either do
what they're supposed to do
as a director and edit,
do that kind of thing.
But Denis really did writing on it,
I mean, pretty wonderful writing where he,
it was more than shaping, Denis.
I think you--
- No, but it was tightening.
Thank you, Eric, but it
was, for me, so inspiring
to see Eric's take on the material,
and it's something that
resonated to the old process.
It was,
but the deal was that
I had Eric that draft
and then I was working.
And then, of course, I needed help,
and Jon came and did a
tremendous amount of work to,
again, dig into, more into characters.
And it was like, it needed, for me,
and I had felt that since the beginning,
that we will need to be a lot of brains
in order to crack the novel,
and a team, that was the idea.
There's a lot of movies
that I love in my life
where when I was looking
at the credits at the end,
there were like five
screenwriters that I admire.
And I was like, I was dreaming
to have that kind of
relationship with the keyboard,
to have like collegiality.
And that's the thing I'm grateful,
that it was that case for Dune.
I'm really, it was a privilege for me
to work with both of these gentlemen.
- And you said that when
you were approaching Eric,
you were looking at him
almost as a historian
and talked about the other
qualities he brought to this.
What were you looking for
from Jon as a collaborator?
- Jon is, was, first of all,
the precision of his
writing, very impressive.
And there's something Jon
also, as deep as Eric does,
but he has a deep culture of the book.
He knows the book more than
anybody else, upside down.
He can recite passage of the book.
It's like if he had participate
to the writing of the book himself.
And there was something
about that deep knowledge
of the book that I needed
to bring on board and also,
to that link with areas
that I was looking for
and to bring the romanticism also.
It was like, I think that bringing in Jon,
it brought a kind of equilibrium
with all that Eric wrote,
my work, and Jon, it brings something
that had the proper equilibrium.
That's what I would say.
- I used to always say that
he put the movie on its feet.
I mean, it was,
or I'm not saying he
brought it down to earth,
(Denis laughs)
but in other words, he was able
to accomplish both in a way.
And he made one of the great, I think,
wonderful transformations,
making one character a
black woman that was a man,
and I think that was sort
of an astounding idea.
But when I read his draft,
you're always very suspect.
What happened here?
- [Vanessa] Right.
- Where did my work go, or something?
- Right.
- I didn't feel that way because
I think he, first of all,
was so true to the book in the right ways
and understood what Denis wanted.
And he did such yeoman's work.
I mean, it's really an incredible task
that I think he did, and my
hat's completely off to him.
- So, sorry.
- Yeah.
I'm just gonna say, I mean, I'm such,
I'm just a more fanciful
writer than Jon is.
And that doesn't mean better, but I just,
I take flights of fancy.
And I won't say what we did,
but when I first wrote
something and then he said,
"That's lovely.
"And how are we gonna afford
the rest of the movie?"
(group laughs)
And that was true.
But I think, as I said, I
think Jon really gave it
the foundation for it that
makes the movie stand up.
- So Jon, I would love to
hear from you then about,
first of all, it sounds like
you had a real history with this book.
Second of all, I cannot even
imagine what it would be like
to know that you were going
to come into this process
after both Eric and Denis
had been working in it.
Were you, I mean, did it feel crazy to be,
I also wonder, I didn't
ask you others about this,
but it's so famous and gigantic, Dune.
I mean, was there, for any of
you, a sense of intimidation
(chuckles) in the face of
this material, or not so much?
It sounds like, Jon,
you're really knowledgeable
about that material.
- I'm sorry, Jon.
I would just say, me, I was
afraid at the beginning.
And I remember having
a discussion with Eric
at the beginning, and
I had been so grateful
that Eric took the baton at the beginning
and start to really try to tame the beast
because I was impressed.
I was like a bit paralyzed
at the beginning, I remember.
That's what I wanted, on my side.
- Yeah.
Jon?
- Well, I did know the book very well.
I read it fairly young at 12 or 13,
and it was one of those books I've reread
every summer vacation for
many years growing up,
so it was an old friend.
- Wow.
- And I'd put it aside for a long time,
but it was shocking when I went back to it
to realize how well I still knew it.
I think there's something about
the plasticity of the mind
in your youth, and the book--
- Was that exciting or intimidating,
that this was such a beloved book for you?
Or both?
- For me, honestly,
it was pure excitement.
I mean, it was exciting to
be rubbing elbows with giants
like Eric and Denis.
It's always exciting to,
just to be in the company
of people with such bodies
of work and such stature.
And yet, I was not nervous about it.
There were challenges to solve,
but the biggest one had been
solved before I came aboard
by Denis' decision to tackle
the novel in two films.
- [Vanessa] Right.
- There is no way to fit
Dune into a single film
even at a Lawrence of Arabia running time
without dire surgery,
without a level of editing
that would amount to amputation.
But in two films,
I think you can get to
the pith of the story.
There's been a lot of talk over the years
about Dune as some sort
of uncrackable story or
unadaptable book.
I've never seen it, honestly.
A couple of storied filmmakers
have taken runs at it.
I think all of those storied filmmakers
were less than perfectly
suited to the material
despite their extraordinary gifts,
and there have been
fountains of creativity
around those efforts.
But Dune as a cinematic
story is not broken.
There are things that I am afraid to adapt
or that I think are nearly unadaptable.
There's a wonderful sci-fi novel
called The Stars My Destination
that's been kicking around
Hollywood for decades,
ever since it was written.
That one might be unadaptable.
Some things nearly are.
But Dune was ready to be a film,
especially in the present day
when the technology of filmmaking
has caught up to the scope of the world.
So for me, honestly, I was excited.
I wanted to roll up my sleeves.
I was ready to jump in
and deeply reassured by
the quality of my partners.
- Yes.
And--
- Is there books,
sorry, is there books,
I would be curious to know, you, Eric,
is there books that you
think that are unadaptable?
- Adaptable?
Well, the only thing,
I wouldn't say a book.
This was, Stanley Kubrick said
you could not make a
movie about the Holocaust
- Oh.
- Yeah.
He said that's untouchable.
I could say something
nasty about another movie,
but I won't, attempted the Holocaust.
But I'm trying to think.
Maybe if, I don't know, maybe the Bible.
I don't know, I don't know.
They've tried and it's what it is.
- Right.
- I don't know.
That's a great question.
I can name other books that
they say that you can't do,
maybe A Thousand Years of Solitude.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
In that's case, it's not easy to do--
- Yeah, I know, it would go on and on.
- So I do wanna go back to a couple things
you guys touched on, but I
first wanted to pick up with Jon
that I think what Denis
must have been referring to
was Liet-Kynes.
Is that correct?
- That's right.
- And why was it your impulse
to make that shift that he referred to?
- We were looking broadly for
justified and organic ways
to strengthen the female
presence in the film.
Dune as a novel has some very powerful
and memorable female characters,
really seminal female characters,
but it's still a mostly male book,
and in some ways, a product of its time.
So we were looking for opportunities.
And the character of Liet-Kynes
is a little peculiar in several ways.
In the very earliest
notebook drafts of Dune,
Liet-Kynes was the protagonist.
And the, when Herbert was
first brainstorming the book,
and this Imperial ecologist
trying to solve the riddle
of this impossible ecosystem
and to tame a planet
without killing what made
it special, he was the hero.
And then over time, he found his way.
I don't know for how
long that was the case,
but certainly, in early notebook notes,
Liet-Kynes was the protagonist,
and then he found his way to
the story of the Atreides clan.
And so there are ways in which
Liet fits a little awkwardly in the story.
There's a,
spoilers for a moment.
There's a relationship in the
novel that bears no fruit.
We find out that Liet-Kynes
is actually the father of
Chani among the Fremen,
which is very awkward in the storytelling
because then, Chani finds
out that Liet-Kynes died
right before she and Paul
are kind of falling in love.
And they have to process
dad dying very quickly
and then pivot to falling in love.
And then we never really talk about
that relationship again in the story.
It's kind of a phantom limb.
And there was certainly,
it would only be confusing
to try to introduce
and then sweep away that relationship
in the narrow confines of a film.
So Liet-Kynes' only relationship
that was left in our book
is really a relationship
to the planet of Arrakis,
to the ecosystem, and to the
desert tribes of the Fremen
with whom Liet has completely integrated.
And the message Liet brings
is so fundamentally maternal
and about healing a world,
and preserving the people,
and finding a way of integrating
the aboriginal tribes,
which were so much a part of her life now,
and this miraculous ecosystem
that's evolved on this planet
that to make her a woman almost
felt obvious after the fact,
that it almost,
as if she should have
been from the beginning.
And of course, this is the human diaspora
10,000 years in our future or more,
so anything that we would
read in a racial text
should no longer apply.
It's not a race blind universe,
but certainly, what we perceive as race
should have moved beyond
any envelope we have for it,
and people are identifying
much more strongly
with their planets of origin,
with the noble houses that govern them,
with societies and orders
they belong to, and so forth.
- And I think that this idea
of changing the gender of Kynes
was absolutely a brilliant
idea that Jim came,
sorry, Jon came with.
And I was very excited by this idea
because it happened at a moment
where I was feeling a disequilibrium,
because Eric had wrote things
that I was deeply in love with,
which was that he had studied
the past of Lady Jessica,
her training as a Bene Gesserit.
All that feminine strength
and that feminine training
was in the earlier draft,
and for reasons of
storytelling, I had to remove,
but I always felt the pain
of removing those beautiful
things that Eric had done,
and still, today, I'm dreaming
to shoot that one in my life.
But that disequilibrium
brought this desire
to find femininity somewhere else,
and Jon came with this idea.
- I'd love to go back just for a moment
for each of you to origins in the sense of
I understand that you each
had a connection with the book
at a young age.
But what would you say for you,
what is essential?
In terms of guiding principles,
what needed to be preserved?
What is it about this piece of work?
What is this fundamentally about
that was so meaningful to you
that you felt this longing to do it?
And was it the same for each of you?
Would you each tell me
that the book and the movie
are about the same things?
Or would you each perhaps
have a different answer?
- I will say that I suspect
that we have all different answers
because the beauty of this book is,
and that's why I think it's a masterpiece,
is that it has so many
layers that you discover
according to your own life experience.
When I read it at 13
years old, I didn't see,
saw the same thing when
I read it again at 20
and again at 30 something.
It's a book that conveys
so many layers and ideas.
For me, one of the most
important idea was the one that,
a specific school, the
Bene Gesserit sisters
are able to channel ancient voice,
a voice coming from their genetic past,
it's a voice from their
ancestors, and to take lessons.
Instead of transforming those voices,
those ghosts into a neurosis,
they are using them as a tool to,
and transform it into a power.
And that, for me, is an idea that,
it really deeply spoke to me
and that I wanted to make sure
that it would be a
prominent in the adaptation.
- What about for you, Eric?
- Well, the book was so
part and parcel of my,
particularly growing up, the culture.
I wouldn't say, and just to be honest,
the book was my favorite
book I've ever read.
It didn't impact me quite that way.
I mean, I thought it was astounding,
and the work he did was
prodigious and creating languages,
and obviously, the
formation of this planet
and all the prescient
things we learned today.
But I mean, Earth Day began in like 1968.
So he was still ahead of that but--
- Right.
- People were very aware
of kind of the loss of
water and everything.
But as you know, from
knowing me as well as you do
since you were a junior high student,
I was kind of a hippie, and
this book reflected my era
in many, many ways.
We don't have to talk about
drugs so much, but that,
the point of view of varying societies
kind of clashing in some ways,
what is the sense of violence,
what is the beauty femininity,
as we talked about, dreams,
I mean, all of these things,
the prescient nature of the
boy who now has this kind of,
which, I mean, was, I think
that was personal to me,
I guess I'd say about,
not that I'm a prophet, but the idea
of what is it coming to
manhood and then what are your,
what do you have to then accomplish
when you set out after that
and what is that next journey.
- [Vanessa] Right.
- Yeah, so I mean, it was,
for me, it wasn't this was a job,
but it was, I think, an
astounding job because of,
it's also the history of the piece
with some great people trying it,
and then this whole challenge
of what can I bring to this.
And so anyway, so I think it's just,
I think they're both right, Jon and Denis,
that I think it's a prism
from where you came from.
And I sort of gravitated to the family,
which I have a big family,
et cetera, et cetera.
And as I say, this kind of,
my favorite movie was 2001,
so that was kind of a
different point of view
of mortality, if you will.
- And Jon, what is it about for you?
- There's so much in it,
and you can go on any
number of deep dives.
And Denis is right that
it's also different books
at different times.
It's very different reading it as a boy
about Paul Atreides's age
than it is reading it now
as the father of an eight-year-old son,
and I definitely attach
to different points in the narrative now.
But for me, the real soul of
Dune is almost an abstraction.
If you read most genre fantasy,
you tend to find characters
representing clear and
bold points of view,
for the king, for honor,
for family, whatever it is.
And in Dune, every
character has this nuanced
and many layered appreciation
of their circumstance
and their place in the world.
Duke Leto Atreides has a code of honor,
and he believes in it.
He has a family that he loves dearly.
He is aware of the Imperium as
a morally dubious enterprise
founded on physical strength
and the doctrine of might makes right.
He knows that there are
tyrants abroad in the land.
He is honorable
and is aware that his
performance of honor is theater,
and that it is good propaganda,
and that it lends him power.
It attracts him followers.
He's aware that it's still honorable
and that that's a good thing.
He knows that this will all end someday
that he is not always,
not in always the good guy
in any one interaction.
They have a very real world grasp
of the complexity of their positions.
They are trying to be good people.
They are aware that they are participating
in systems that are imperfect
and systems that have
darkness within them.
They try to steer in the best directions.
To some extent they
embrace a certain fatalism
that this is what they were born to,
that the system is beyond
their power to change.
But at every level of the book,
Jessica as a Bene Gesserit,
Stilgar as a Fremen, Paul and
Leto Atreides as noblemen,
rulers of a planet, rivals
of other great houses,
all of them appreciate the
complexity of their position
and will, in private moments,
philosophize with each other about that.
It felt, in that way, like real life.
We all know that we love
our families desperately
and that our families
are a little bit broken
and have some baggage and some skeletons.
We love what we do for a living
and it's a headache and a drag.
Everything's like that.
We love ourselves, and we know
the ways in which we fail.
Dune seems to model that nuanced, complex,
multilayered thinking that
can entertain contradictions
and complexities at every
level of the storytelling.
And when I first read it,
I think I had never
read a piece of fiction
in which characters thought like that.
And if there was anything
I was hoping to preserve into
the film, it was that sense
of many layered
comprehension of the world.
- I would like go back
to this idea of pitfalls
because I found it so
exciting to hear about.
Denis, what were the greatest challenges
in making this a script?
You've already, all of you
have actually talked about
the difficulty of compressing this
and what you did in dividing it up.
But are there other areas,
are there areas where you think,
wow, we really did this
exactly as I wanted,
and some areas where you think,
ugh, I wish I still had this, or I,
you referenced some of Eric's work
that you wish was still in it.
But what was really, really hard here?
- The thing is that, I
will state the obvious.
The idea was that it was important
for me to honor the dream
that when I read the book, to try,
I had an appetite for that book,
and I wanted the people
who had loved the book
as much as I did will find
some respect of the world,
of the poetry of the book.
At the same time,
I wanted my mother to
understand the movie.
I wanted, to the people that don't,
knew nothing about this
world will feel welcome,
and so to balance information.
There are so many cultures
and so many tribes in this,
to find the right balance, to give enough,
and not put too much
exposition at the beginning
that would crush the, that the
audience would feel crushed
under the amount of information.
That was probably, for
me, the main challenge,
I would say that at the
beginning of the book,
the book started by saying something
like beginnings are very delicate times.
And I will say that definitely,
how to open this movie
was the big challenge,
how to approach it.
At the beginning, we tried to
be more faithful to the book
and realized quickly that,
not quickly, not quickly.
We realized at one point,
after a lot of work,
that we had to deviate a
little bit from the book
in order to make a soft,
a more gentle introduction
to the world so people
will have enough knowledge
to not feel lost at the beginning.
It's a bit boring answer,
but that's the truth.
- What about for you, Eric?
What were the pitfalls
you saw going into it?
- Well, I find the same pitfalls
in a lot of science fiction.
As I say, I'm not as steeped in it.
Sometimes I find things hard to believe,
and I found some of that in
this book, to be quite honest.
It's just my probably
skeptical nature of things.
- And I love you for that. (laughing)
- Thank you.
I mean, I like to poke
sticks in eyes a little bit.
So I think it was not to emphasize cliches
that sometimes arise and to
make it as literate as possible.
I mean, you can take other
avenues to make the people real,
like in any movie.
So I mean, I think I approached
it the way I do any job
that you have different
voices of different people
that have different psychological aspects
and come from different places.
And it's really no different
than if you're writing a sci,
I mean, I think I've said
this once to Denis before,
that I was once talking to Francis Coppola
about writing something and he said,
a science fiction thing, and he said,
"Well, as long as you're
not watching a chandelier,
"it's fine."
So you have the same rules
apply, in other words,
to Shakespeare or anything else,
that the characters have to resonate,
have some emotional balance,
all those things, or imbalance.
So I'd say those are the
same problems, and that,
there is a weight of
the fact that it's Dune.
In other words, I would say
I haven't adapted anything,
that I can think of that consequence.
It's like the famous thing
is that bad books make good movies.
And not that Dune's a bad book,
but then I'm safer with Forrest Gump.
You know what I'm saying?
Or a bad play or something
because you can go off
in flights are fancy
and bend as you will.
You couldn't do that here.
I think there was
obligations, and I think that,
thanks to Denis and Jon,
they were maintained.
I'm not sure, if it
was left to my devices,
it would be the same movie,
to be honest with you but--
- And do you recall a
particular scene or element
that gave you grief?
- No, not really, not really.
I think it was,
no, I think everything had its challenges
and also had its solutions.
I did, I mean, I wish I had
had Jon at my right hand
who knows the book so well.
I did have a woman who was a PhD in Dune.
So she told me what was the
gospel, according to her anyway,
and I thought that was impressive.
And she did know the thing.
I think she was helpful to me.
But I mean, I guess, I'm
being honest with you,
I don't approach things very differently
from anything I decide to do.
And the bigger problem for me
is the decision to decide to do it
because I don't wanna really
fall on my face, you know.
I'd rather that I left with a nice legacy.
But anyway, thanks to these guys,
it ended up being something special.
- And Denis, was that for
you a difficult decision
when you decided to split this into two?
It sounds like it was
a necessary decision,
but it also alters
structurally what you're doing.
- It was very spontaneous,
I think coming from an instinct
of survival. (laughing)
- You said, "What am I gonna do?"
- So it's like, I
remember once, I took the,
I made the deal with the Jen Derry.
And of course, first thing you
do is you go back to the book
and spontaneously, I went back.
The first thing I said, that
we have to make two movies,
part one, part two, and
that was, and it was not,
I didn't have to convince nobody.
Everybody agreed spontaneously.
(Vanessa laughs)
And now, the challenge was
where to end the first part,
and then that was like
a lot of exploration.
There was different ideas on the table.
- And how did you make that decision?
What were some different
points you were considering?
- Well, as Jon could be more
eloquent than me about that,
but I would say that there is in the book
a natural breaking point.
There's a moment where
there's a time lapse,
there's a time jump, sorry, between,
and that would have been a natural way
to end the first part.
But the problem with that is that
it meant that our main
characters, Paul and Jessica,
had to be introduced to a
new culture and learn things
and went through a process of
being accepted by the Fremen,
and that felt like the
beginning of a story.
It didn't feel like a last act of a movie.
It felt like suddenly, we
were starting something,
opening a new door, and it felt too heavy
to put that at the end of the project.
It really felt a disequilibrium.
And we tried and there was
beauty in it, but it didn't,
quickly, we realized that
it would be better to end
as Paul and Jessica were
going toward this culture
instead of embracing it.
That's what I would say.
Does it make sense what I'm saying?
- Yes. (laughing)
Hmm, yes.
Yeah.
And Jon, were you sort of
involved in that calibration?
- Deeply, and we tried many things.
- Yeah.
- And we were trying to thread the needle
in a bunch of ways.
That time jump was the
first obvious target,
because if you can go
away after the first film
and then make a second
movie and you come back
and it's two or three
years later in reality
and it's also two or three
years later in the story,
everything works out.
You can have your actors
as tanned and bearded
as you need them to be to be
themselves a few years older.
So it did seem like a natural
target, but it thrust us
toward that Lawrence
of Arabia running time
which can limit the life
and audience of a film.
And as Denis said, it was
a kind of big fourth act.
What we did find, I think in part,
we only saw the clarity of it
having winnowed the
story of the first film
down to an elegant shape.
A lot of things fell by the wayside.
The guiding logic again and again proved
that we are following the
Atreides family, and above all,
we are following Paul Atreides
through a metamorphosis.
And everything that does not
serve the telling of the story
of that metamorphosis became deemphasized,
even things we dearly loved.
And when you focus so
narrowly on that clan
and that boy coming of age,
then you see a three-act story, a tragedy
of being drawn out of the
world of the familiar,
of contending in a strange
new land with sinister forces,
of breaking with the family, of the fall,
and then the gleam of hope at the end
when the dynasty survives
in him and in his mother.
And that felt Shakespearean.
It felt like it had a natural arc.
And so it started to
feel more and more alien
to then tell another
whole leg of the story
and start new thing 'cause the
tragedy had defined itself.
But we really found it
by trying to make the story
fit into the first film
and focusing with increasing intensity
on the family and the hero,
and that showed us where
the story needed to stop,
in the very moment where
he's leaving one world
and entering another.
- Yeah, I could see that
being very challenging.
- Well, I think it was also complicated
because there was a question of whether
he should shoot two movies at once.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Vanessa] Right.
- And that was just an interesting,
in one way, you can save a lot of money.
Another way, it can be a disaster,
so there's some practical considerations.
But when we were dealing
with the storytelling,
it had to do with, well,
where are we gonna end this
even if we're blending into movie two
that you're gonna release a year from now,
so it was really an interesting situation
that resolved itself, fortunately.
- I am going to take a moment
to ask about a scene that I really loved
and just see if anyone can remember
the origins of this scene.
I really enjoyed the scene where Duke Leto
has to rescue the crew from the harvester.
Was that a scene in the book?
I don't, yes.
- Yeah, it's a very good interesting scene
where the three of us had
an impact on that scene.
It's a famous scene in
the book, but in the book,
let's say that Paul is less involved.
He's more in the backseat.
He's more like a spectator, yeah.
And Eric brought the idea
of Paul getting out of the ornithopter,
bringing Paul involved,
involving Paul with the rescue,
being on the ground.
The idea was that it will
be his first encounter
with the deep desert,
that it will have a resonance inside him,
that he will strangely feel like at home
in this foreign landscape,
and that moment, reorient
the scene in a different way.
It was more than just a rescue.
It was like an encounter,
a spiritual encounter with the desert
and with that creature that will come.
And then from Eric ideas,
Jon came and slightly shifted where,
brought this idea of Paul
having hallucinations.
I think that came from Jon.
Sometimes, the truth is,
and it's a thing I love about filmmaking,
is collective creativity,
meaning that sometimes--
- Remember--
- I don't remember who
got the idea exactly.
So gentlemen, if I'm,
because there's so much decisions.
- It doesn't matter.
- But at the end, it's
the movie, it's teamwork.
But I will say that
it's a beautiful scene,
a scene that is a good
example of collaborative
that evolve in a beautiful way
to tie in the roots of the ideas
and then evolve through
different ends on the keyboard.
And I'm very, I love that scene.
- Yeah, that is--
- [Eric] Me too.
- It's a very striking scene from the book
because Dune is a novel that leaves
a lot of its biggest
moments of action off stage.
And you get reports of this
great big piece of action
that just happened.
You have characters discussing
the aftermath and reacting.
But he just wasn't very
interested, for the most part,
in writing a lot of big action
set pieces in his books,
and so they tended to be in the background
as like map paintings, and you
get actors in the foreground
talking about what it all means.
- Like theater.
- Yeah, exactly.
This is a scene in the book
that is operatically told
as an action set piece,
really one of the only ones.
And I think it's one of the scenes
that everyone comes away
from the book remembering.
There are a few things that
people who've read the book once
a long time ago will tell you about,
and they'll tell you about the Gom Jabbar,
and they'll tell sandworm
eating the sand crawler,
and they'll remember that moment.
So it was an exciting scene
to focus on, but there too,
like every scene in the novel,
it has too many layers and
too many conversations in it
to fit into the film.
And so there, again, it was a
process of iteratively finding
the essence of the sequence.
- And was this quite an
iterative process in general?
Would you say, for all of you,
compared to other projects,
films you've worked on,
was this quite iterative?
Were there many, many, many,
many, many, many drafts,
or just sort of,
yes, okay, a yes.
- Yeah, I mean, I, Eric
and Denis can talk,
Eric can talk about his process with Denis
'cause that preceded me, but for my part,
the shape of it was that I
came in and took the book apart
and did a big adaptive work of my own,
which then amalgamated
with Eric and Denis' work
and pulled all of their finest
creative flights into it
and sort of mushed it
together in one thing.
And then Denis and I turned that over
again and again and
again four or five times
in these very intensely
collaborative writing sessions
where we'd lock ourselves
in a hotel suite for a week.
And he would come and go,
and when he left, I'd write.
He'd come back the next day
and we'd talk from nine
until two in the afternoon.
I would write until midnight
and send him my pages and go to sleep.
And he'd come in in the
morning having read them,
and we'd talk until two or
three, and we'd do it again
until by the end of the week,
he would leave at two or
three in the afternoon.
I would instantly fall asleep
and sleep until midnight
and wake up and then write
until six in the morning,
send him my pages.
- Now I'm curious by this
process, and I would love to know,
Denis, if you have pursued
this process in the past.
- Not, not, no.
It was the first time
that I was working with,
it's not true.
I had wrote myself a screenplay
with the help of another writer.
But after that,
I came onboard a project that
had been written already,
so it was a different approach.
It was like to try to bring a screenplay
closer to my sensibility by
rewriting with the writer,
story boarding, rewriting again, but not,
starting from scratch like
that with Eric and Jon, it was,
it had been a long time,
and I was missing that
part of the process.
Writing is so, it's so
difficult, but it's so beautiful.
I mean, I'm grateful that
I had a chance to work.
Even on the side, even if
I was just on the side,
I had great fun watching
Eric and Jon working.
For me, it was fascinating.
- Yeah.
- At the very end of the process,
when there were particular
points of the movie
that were focuses of Denis'
creative concentration,
then there was a lot of overleaving
where Denis was like the
conductor in orchestra.
And there were things Eric came in touch
and I came in touch.
We were writing to a line by line level
and just sanding and sanding
until the thing took--
- Yeah, because at one point,
what happened, like any movie,
was the reality team of
the production, a budget,
restrictions, which is part of the,
and then that's, Jon
came, Eric came, and we,
so it was like a sculpture at that moment.
Everybody was chipping to make sure
that it will finally have the most
let's say beautiful shape
in the circumstances.
- Now we all know the saying
too many cooks spoil the,
whatever it is it spoils.
- Broth.
- [Vanessa] Apparently, I
don't know the saying, but--
- Broth.
- It sounds like the
opposite in this case.
To what do you attribute that?
Is there anything to,
do you know why is it
simply that each of you,
you had complimentary skills
or perhaps personalities?
- There was the book, as Eric said,
mentioned at the beginning.
We had obligation toward the book,
and it was like it's an object
that as such a strong persona.
Either you like or you
don't like the book,
it still has a strong personality,
and I think that it helped us to shape.
I think that's my take on it.
- But I do think, just since
we're talking to writers here,
I think this is a unique situation.
I've been through some,
as I said, many of these
where you have conflicting
kind of writing.
One person writes
different than the other,
and it can get very kind of hairy.
And rewriting is very difficult
because you're trying to maintain a tone
and not have a separate
voice and change everything.
I think Denis is right.
I mean, I think the book
is such a grounded centerpiece for this.
And then everybody had some great respect
for what it was had to say,
what we would like to say with it.
And Denis was a wonderful
maestro, a wonderful master
of keeping all the boats moving in line.
So it was a unique,
I'm telling you.
I've had a lot of 'em which
didn't work out so good.
- But isn't it interesting too,
because I don't think
one can always correlate
those wonderful, magical work
relationships with good films.
I mean, I think--
- Actually, that's true.
- No, I'm agreeing, I'm agreeing
because I think that's--
- So it's shocking that
that is what happened.
- Well, varying voices don't,
sometimes don't make one point of view.
I think people can take
advantage of that too.
That's a whole different conversation.
- Mm-hmm, it's true, yeah.
It's true what you're saying, Eric.
- I think I may have gone over my time,
so I think I better announce the Q&A
with the Academy Gold Alumni
and go to our first
questioner, Haley Bartel.
- Hi, everybody.
Thank you so much for being here.
This has been amazing.
My brain is exploding, and huge
congratulations on the film.
So my question is for everyone here,
and it's kind of a general
world building question.
So when you were conceiving
the worlds of your films,
are you intentionally
thinking of and constructing
internal elements that reflect
sort of the internal elements
of your characters' arc and theme?
Or do the worlds sort of
spring fully formed as Athena?
- What is it?
Your question is about the use
of landscape or architecture
to express the internal
journey of the characters,
is that what you're saying?
- Yeah, just the sort of integral elements
that exist in the world of the film
as you're creating that world.
- I apologize.
Maybe I'm misunderstanding your question,
but definitely, there was like,
landscape was a very important component
of the storytelling here where the way,
if you look at the way the
movie evolves, the color palette
and the way we are embracing the landscape
at different moment was
used as a way to externalize
the condition in which
the main character, Paul,
because the idea was that we
will focus as much as possible
the story on Paul, his point of view.
In a perfect world, I would
have made just the movie
about Paul and his mother,
but we had to go outside from time to time
in order to understand the story.
And definitely, architecture
and landscape were used
in a cinematic way, I think, to express.
And it's the beauty of
doing science fiction
because you can create everything,
so you have like the full,
you are like a god.
You can create all the elements
you need in order to express
some psychological component of the,
I don't know if what I'm saying
makes sense in English
right now. (laughing)
Yeah.
- [Eric] It does.
- That's the thing I love
about sci-fi is that you,
it's like a living sculpture
where you are actually
having an impact on the,
but it will be the same
with any movies, in fact.
It's part of the beauty
of finding resonance
into the elements or into the landscape
in order to help the audience
to understand characters in their journey.
- All right.
Our next question is from Desmond Jackson.
- Now, if I may add, the
story we're following
is the story of a boy.
The deeper he goes into the desert,
the more he learn about himself,
the more he has an introspective journey.
It's a very introspective movie,
so it's like that landscape,
that tremendous impact.
That's why the movie was
shot with massive wides
and very intimate shots.
There was no in between a lot.
It's like, it's really
embracing that point of view
of a boy discovering a
new world, a new culture
and embracing that culture.
- All right, Desmond?
- Hi, guys.
Thank you so much.
Y'all have literally been dropping gems
throughout this whole session,
so thank you so much, and fantastic film.
My question is also similar to Haley's
in terms of world building.
I wanted to know if you guys
had any specific suggestions
in terms of introducing worlds
and the rules and class systems and races
and different planet
structures and everything
to like an unfamiliar audience
without being too expository
with the character's dialogue.
- That's, if I were gonna talk
about the pitfalls of Dune,
I would talk about the rules.
I grew up reading a ton of
fantasy and science fiction
when I was just a kid, and
then I got tired of it.
I put it away.
And when I was in high school and college,
I was reading literary fiction
and I was going to be a novelist someday.
And I didn't really come
back to science fiction
until I started screenwriting,
where there was an appetite for it,
and I had a foundation, and I
ended up working in this file,
but a lot of my heart
was in the philosophical
and very personal investigations
of literary fiction.
There was a way to write Dune
where you kind of went deep
and Dungeons and Dragonsy
about all the rules
and the orders and the people
and just really got into the
weeds of the world building.
And there can be fun in that,
but there's very little poetry in it.
And above all, it gobbles oxygen.
In any movie, there's not much space.
Movies are small.
They are novellas.
And so everything you put in
goes into the expense of something else.
And the more you are putting
in the Tin Makers Guild,
and the dragons of Cora,
and the nebulons of Troy,
whatever you've invented for your world,
the more you talk about that,
the less your characters
are living and breathing
in front of the audience.
And so the beautiful guiding
light in this production
was Denis and his desire to tell a story
through the pure language of cinema.
And he's saying that
about one of the talkiest
novels in science fiction,
and he says, "My goal, my ideal here
"would be a nearly silent film."
- With that, we failed. (laughing)
- (laughing) I know.
- But as a compass needle,
that guided us in the
exposition of everything.
So to answer your question
very programmatically,
if you wanna build a fantasy
world with intricate rules,
do write them down, get Dungeons
and Dragonsy about them.
Have your taxonomies, your histories,
and then don't ever talk about it.
You don't need to.
It will color the work
because you know it.
It will change the way
your characters speak
because you know where they've come from,
you know how they live.
It will be implied.
It will be poetry.
It will be in the background,
and that's where it should live.
What you want to be doing
is telling human stories
in the foreground.
And so you wanna be as
economical as possible
about actually being explicit
about any of that world building.
- Thank you.
Our next question is from Marlon Desilva.
- Thank you so much, Vanessa,
and thank you all for this
great insightful panel.
I've learned so much.
A question I had thinking
about the movie was,
did you all have any visual
references to refer to
while writing the screenplay?
And how were they helpful when
bringing those words to life?
- If I may, I would just say
that something that was
fascinating for me is that
when we started the work,
Eric started the work,
and I was, at the time, doing Blade Runner
and I was like overwhelmed
finishing the movie on time.
And I remember that Eric had done,
and still today, those images haunted me
as I shot the movie.
He had done a beautiful
research, historical research
that involved science fiction images,
but also historical based
on medieval research.
It really, all those images helped me to,
I was, at the time,
starting to shape the world.
I had images in myself,
but I remember the influence
of Eric research on his side
that I thought was really
poetic and insightful.
And then when Jon came on board,
at the time, it was later,
so I had the time to start
concept art and had the time to,
so when, I remember sometimes
Jon was writing and saying,
"By the way, what does it look like?"
And then I was showing him an image,
and then he was like, "Whoa."
It was interesting that
I was drawing the movie
as it was written, and then
sometimes, I was sharing.
Both, it was a dance between that.
So that's what I wanted to say.
- Thank you.
And our last question
is from Magna Nagaraji.
- Hi, you got my name
perfectly right. (laughing)
So I really loved the movie,
and thank you so much for
taking the time to speak to us.
Obviously, the soundtrack
is very haunting,
but here's my question.
So Chani's character doesn't
have like a speaking part
until like the last,
like about 30 minutes of the film, right,
but she has such a huge
presence throughout the movie.
And I wanted to know if that's
something that you guys wrote
or is that something
that was like directed?
- Hmm.
- It was written.
- [Eric] I remember it was written.
- Yes, yes, yes, it was written.
- I think it's written too.
- It was written.
The idea here was that Paul is
obsessed with those visions.
And then finally, when
he finally meets her,
then there's a bit of an
exchange, a contact that is made.
But of course, all this is promises,
promise for the second movie.
It's like, it's a bet that
we did with having at the end
just to, we introduced characters that,
and I was praying that they
would be a part two (laughing)
because otherwise, it would be weird.
But yeah, so.
I don't know if you want to
add something, Jon or Eric.
- Well, I think that intention was there,
but I also think that
the power of Chani's presence in the film
is it flows directly from cinema.
It's from the very potent
performance of Zendaya herself
and the way Denis frames
her again and again
in the language of dreams.
She is the character who
most inter-penetrates
the real world that Paul
is adventuring through
and the prophetic world
that he's experiencing
through his unreliable
glimpses of the future.
And so because she lives
in both those worlds,
she acquires a higher significance.
And of course, she greets
us at the top of the movie.
It's her voice who frames
the historical conflict
that will play out throughout the film.
- One thing I will say is that,
I agree, of course, with
what Eric and Jon said,
but I was, as a director, I
was mesmerized by Zendaya,
by her presence, by her
power, the magnetism.
And I shot more.
I had more.
I got, let's say, artistically
excited by this actress
that I think absolutely
has such a strong presence
and a strength onscreen.
So I shot more, but it respected
the frame that was written.
That's what I will say.
But there's more images.
There's more in a way
that the more I was shooting with Zendaya,
the more I wanted to shoot.
So that's why I am looking
forward to do part two.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you all so much.
I think that probably brings
us to an end at exactly 5:01.
I feel a sense of pride.
I won't lie.
- Great job, great job.
- (laughing) Thank you.
- Thank you all.
Thank you, Vanessa.
Thank you, it was lovely.
- Thank you so much, everybody.
- Thank you, Eric and Jon.
- Thanks so much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for participating
in the Academy's Visiting
Artist Film series
FilmAid edition for writing.